well covet quarantine has been an
extraordinary uh productive period for
president joe biden and i'm not kidding
around i mean think back to when donald
trump had coveted and he was stuck in a
hospital at one point receiving
supplemental oxygen sending uh
li-laced tweets at the time
going out and exposing his secret
service detail to covid when he made
them drive him around the block in his
suv i mean just a pathetically globally
humiliating covet period for donald
trump we can't even really call it
coveted quarantine because he wasn't
properly isolating joe biden on the
other hand we already knew
had overseen and authorized the killing
of al qaeda terrorist ayman al-zawahiri
legitimate questions about the legal
framework for these killings you know
i'm right there with you but an
accomplishment by international
standards
an extraordinarily strong jobs report
late last week which we will get to
later
but the big news oh and gas prices
declining 54 days in a row and i'm kind
of kidding because as you know i don't
actually think presidents have much to
do with gas prices but by their
standards another accomplishment and now
the really really big news over the
weekend the senate approving a bill to
fight climate change and cut drug costs
not insulin unfortunately thanks to
republicans but we will get to that as
well but we are really racking up
major accomplishments here for joe biden
and it couldn't come as a better time as
democrats are surging in midterm
election polls tomorrow we will talk
about could this be one of the worst
midterms for republicans
after a democrat takes the white house
the answer is yes it could be
but we will get to that tomorrow reuters
reporting the u.s senate sunday passed a
sweeping
430 billion dollar bill
intended to fight climate change lower
drug prices
raise some corporate taxes in a major
victory for joe biden which democrats
hope will help them in november after a
marathon
27-hour weekend session of debate and
republican efforts to derail the package
the senate approved the legislation
known as the inflation reduction act by
a 51 to 50 party line vote vice
president kamala harris cast the
tie-breaking ballot this sends the
measure to the house of representatives
for a vote probably friday
they're expected to pass it send it to
the white house for joe biden's
signature
the senate is making history said an
elated senate majority leader chuck
schumer
to americans who have lost faith that
congress can do big things this bill is
for you
schumer says the legislation contains
the boldest clean energy package in
american history to fight climate change
while reducing consumer costs for energy
and some medicines
the legislation is aimed at reducing
carbon emissions and shifting consumers
to green energy cutting prescription
drug costs for the elderly and
tightening enforcement on taxes for
corporations and the wealthy the measure
pays for itself and reduces the federal
deficit over time democrats contend it
will help down uh bring down inflation
economists have generally speaking
agreed with that
from the washington post
senate approves inflation reduction act
clinching long-delayed health and
climate bill the party-line vote marks a
major achievement for democrats after
more than a year of wrangling over the
centerpiece of president biden's
economic agenda this is a really really
big deal and zoom out for a moment and
think about the last two weeks for joe
biden
understanding that i am giving you a
public analysis
understanding as you and i have talked
about before
that not all of the things i'm about to
mention directly relate to joe biden
we have essentially full employment
right now more than 500 thousand new
jobs um in the latest job jobs report
unemployment down to three point five
percent
this is
an extraordinary jobs report and
unemployment situation by any measure
i'm in al zawahiri major al-qaeda
terrorist killed now we might say that
was illegal okay well i'm not
disagreeing with that but from the point
of view of the accomplishments biden can
now claim in terms of saying reward
democrats in november
uh inflation reduction act with major
uh advances in a number of different
areas doing a number of good things and
by the way expected to push down
inflation which i believe tomorrow
tomorrow we are getting or no on
wednesday we are getting the july
inflation numbers i believe they are
going to look much better and i believe
it is going to bump up the market etc um
and now in addition gas prices coming
down about 20 i mean again it's sort of
a joke i don't think biden had anything
to do with them going up nor coming down
but when we say it's the economy stupid
and people look at certain indicators to
determine are things going well or not
going well
that's one of the things that they look
at now
fox news and right-wing media are
calling this bill
uh a social bill spending spree
as if health care is some kind of
frivolous pet project or a social issue
when it's not like it's going to be for
gay marriage or who the hell knows what
republicans are saying democrats are
going to pay the price for this bill i
don't believe that that's the case but
we will know in under three months now
one other thing
diabetics should remember when it's time
to vote and really everybody should
remember that one of the amendments that
republican senators killed was a 35 cap
on insulin
senate republicans yesterday stripped a
proposed 35 a month cap on out-of-pocket
spending on insulin for patients
enrolled in private insurance
the senate parliamentarian earlier ruled
the provision
is not primarily related to the federal
budget so it's not eligible to be passed
by 50 votes they needed 60 votes only
seven republicans voted for it so the
insulin amendment failed
by three votes
these people are disgusting they truly
are
and we will see in november
who
this is all good or bad for let's just
leave it there one of our sponsors today
is bluechu a unique online service
delivering the same active ingredients
as viagra and cialis in a chewable form
and at a fraction of the cost and
they're giving my audience an entire
month supply for free so if you think
you could benefit from an extra boost of
confidence
when it's time
all you have to do is take a short quiz
on their website a licensed doctor
approves your prescription the
medication comes straight to your home
within days in a discreet package no
driving around to the doctor's office or
the pharmacy no waiting around no
awkward conversations with your doctor
all of blue chews tablets are made in
the usa the entire process is just a few
clicks
go to bluechew.com the link is
underneath this video they'll give you
an entire month's supply for free
when you use the promo code pacman all
you have to do is pay five dollars
shipping